the president is crisscrossing the
country with the election
just over 50 days away but late this
week i had the honor of visiting the
white house and sitting down with the
president of the united states
for an exclusive interview on the rose
garden patio just off the oval office
take a look mr president thanks so much
for doing this
joe biden has indicated after the
woodward information came out
that your handling of the coronavirus
and that situation was
not only despicable but it's almost
criminal what do you say to joe biden
i think a statement like that is
criminal because we did a much better
job than
he could ever have done as you know he
was months later before he even thought
the ban was a good thing and ultimately
he had to apologize for what he did
we would have lost hundreds of thousands
of lives and what i said to woodward was
actually good i said calm we need calm
we don't need panic
they want me to jump up and down and
start screaming is everyone going to die
is everyone gonna that's not what
leadership is about i'm a cheerleader
for the country
we need calm that's all i've said and by
the way that was done
after that was done after i had already
banned china
right from coming into the country that
was in february 31st
so jenny and i took tremendous steps
everybody knew how i feel otherwise i
wouldn't be banning china then shortly
there after i banned europe
we saved hundreds of thousands of lives
with each one of those bands
and say probably two or two and a half
million lives by doing what we did
early so you say that your timing was
good but let me ask you about bob
woodward's timing
he did this interview with you on
february 7th where you talked about how
dangerous the virus was
and yet he waited until september seven
months later
to announce to the american public how
dangerous you said it was
was his timing good look he is a
an opportunist not a bad guy to be
honest he's doing his thing
his first book i didn't have anything to
do with it and he wrote things that were
false and
untrue and i could have straightened it
out and i said let me do i took quite a
few phone calls 16 phone calls or
something like that
and we had some good conversations not
long but good conversations
and i don't even know if the book is
good or bad i mean i can tell you that
what
this says is that i said don't panic we
don't want panic
you know the press will make everything
look bad because it's fake the fake news
most of it i'd say 85
unfortunately that's the number we're up
to but uh
i discussed with him lots of different
things i think
they were very good discussions we'll
see how it comes out
but on this subject if you look and he's
actually being hit because if he thought
it was wrong
then he should have reported it early he
you know if lives were going to be lost
he should have reported it early
the truth is he didn't think there was
anything wrong with it and i think that
he thought it was surprising that the
press even picked it up
it's fake news it's all fake news well
in fact when he called you in march
a month later you said to him i didn't
want to cause panic and that's precisely
uh you know why i as a leader
didn't go out and just say everyone's
going to die well go out and look at the
great leaders of
the world winston churchill stood on the
rooftops in london
very calm making speeches winston
churchill
you want calmness you don't want
somebody going to be jumping up and down
i could do that too i could jump up and
down say oh this is terrible this is
terrible
we want strength we want leadership and
we don't want panic
what about the vaccine itself now joe
biden and kamala harris and
the the gallup survey that they just did
says that the
the acceptance of the vaccine is pretty
much going along political lines
the democrats don't want to accept it
because they don't trust it because it's
coming out of your administration they
don't want it because they don't they
think it's going to make me look good
and it wins the election for me but
we're very close to a vaccine we also
have already come out with therapeutics
if you look at remdisservier and others
uh the plasma you take a look at the
things that we've come out with already
and the
the number were 85 better in terms of uh
fatalities you look at the kind of
numbers i don't know if you've been
seeing this but
we're really rounding the corner and
this is actually without anything
further than we already have but we have
some very good things out there already
in terms of i would say in terms of you
can't use the word cure yet but pretty
pretty close to a cure you're going to
be pretty close to a cure
the vaccine itself i mean it could come
out in october but
whether it's october november december
it's going to come out very soon
we have great companies they're very
advanced and the results are going to be
very good
well you know the numbers you're correct
the numbers are going down
and there's a question as to whether or
not the lockdown works that maybe people
need to get
outside uh and if the coronavirus cases
are dropping and joe biden now is coming
out and saying
you know on the advice of a scientist i
would shut it all down again
how do you think that's going to work
for him well it would be a disaster and
we're setting records on job production
you know we're 10.4 million for the last
four months nobody's ever seen numbers
like this we're sending records by
millions and millions of jobs uh the
country's coming back it's a super v
it's beyond a v it's a super v
retail sales are beyond any number they
were ever at i mean think of it we're
doing numbers now
as we're rounding i think the final turn
and that's with
without it doesn't matter with or
without now having the vaccine is great
it's going to happen very soon could
happen in october it could very well
happen october but
we're rounding the turn on the virus
they have to open up
it's only the democrats that are closed
and in my opinion they're closed for
political reasons they have
north carolina you have michigan you
have a couple of other states that are
new york i mean look at new york what
they're doing in new york that poor city
with the restaurants you can't go to a
restaurant like a ghost town
what they've done to new york and people
are leaving is disgraceful between cuomo
and de blasio that combination i've
never seen anything like it in my life
it's it's look coming from new york it's
a very
sad thing to witness but we have to open
up our states totally open them
they're keeping them closed because they
want on november 3rd they want to have
the numbers as bad as possible
based on the numbers that you're seeing
it's not even affecting this but
probably it would be better if these
states were open forget about numbers
though
the people that are inside those
lockdowns
they're suffering between depression
losing their jobs
drugs alcohol all of the different
things that are happening to those
people
that's causing much more damage than the
virus itself well what's interesting you
mentioned north carolina
voting has already started in north
carolina they're on lockdown how do you
think that impacts
people who want to vote for you well
look i like people to go out and vote
but if they want to sign something you
know you have solicited and unsolicited
in the country they're going to send out
80 million
unsolicited in other words people that
don't even know what a ballot is all of
a sudden
here comes the ballot now we don't even
know if the people are going to get it
that's my problem supposing they're not
sending them to republican neighborhoods
supposing they're not sending them to
wherever or supposing the people aren't
giving them back
or they go out and they harvest them
somebody could be either way
but the democrats seem to do that i mean
they played that game for a long time
yeah i prosecuted those cases
well you you might have to prosecute a
lot more
the fact is they're playing very dirty
80
million ballots we never had any number
like that anywhere
close to that and you're going to see a
mess on election night that's going to
be
it's going to be legendary and all they
have to do is say
go out and vote or request a ballot get
what's called a solicited ballot
where or absentee a lot of people use
the word absentee
get an absentee ballot will you request
it it comes to you you vote
and you send it back that's different
but they're just sending out
all over they're sending out 80 million
well they're generic and a lot of people
don't know what to do with them a lot of
people have moved a lot of people have
died the registration rules a lot of
them haven't been purged it's a whole
problem no how about
issues they don't even want to have
signatures they're not confirming they
don't want to have signatures verified
where are they sending them who are they
sending them to who's sending them back
who's sending it back well it's a very
it's so
unconstitutional it's so dishonest and
you have states that can't even do small
elections can you do about it
well we're in courts and uh many many
courts right now and hopefully the
courts are going to decide because if
they don't you're going to have one hell
of a mess
on election night so you talked about
election night i want to talk about
election night also but it brings me to
the issue of law and order
uh and and you when you ran in 2016 you
were the law and order candidate it's
almost prescient to think that four
years later
that is that one of the main issues so
uh we've got this anarchy going on
in the streets we've got towns and
run by and and states run by democrat
governors and mayors who are refusing to
allow the national guard to come in
there are people in those cities and
states who
want order to come in but you can't go
in unless they request your help
every problem what are you gonna do
let's say there are there are threats
they say
that they're going to threaten riots if
they lose
on election night assuming we get a a
winner on election night what are you
going to do
we'll put them down very quickly we have
the right to do that we have the power
to do that if we want
look it's called insurrection we just
send in and we we do it very easy i mean
it's very easy i'd rather not do that
because there's no reason for it
but if we had to we'd do that and put it
down within minutes within minutes
minneapolis they were having problems we
sent in the national guard within a half
an hour that was the end of the problem
it all went away and you look at kenosha
look at the problems they had in fact
the sheriff's there the police chief
they're all on my side 100 law
enforcement all over the country is on
my side and i will say this look
we have even with the horrible things
that are going on in new york
and chicago run by all run by democrats
everything we're talking about you know
is run by democrats we're not talking
about
one republican place it's all run by
democrats even the police chiefs they're
all quitting all over the country yes
every single i think i saw 15 or 20.
every single one of them is from a
a democrat city look
before china sent us the plague before
the play came in
we had the best crime numbers in history
when the play came it changed things
let's face it it changed things
but all of the problems are in
democrat-run cities they're badly run
the taxes are too much they they want to
defund their police
biden is all in that he hasn't still to
this day
use the term law and order he's afraid
to use the term because he's going to
lose he would lose the radical left
supporters that he's got
if they even show up for him because
there's a question as to whether or not
they're going to show up
but they don't want to talk about law
and order one other thing
you have a lot of people living in the
suburbs you know it well you live in
west chester you know it well
i ended a rule a regulation where
low-income housing
has been forced into the suburbs and
this has been going on for a long time
but especially so under biden and obama
i ended it i terminated it's not going
to happen anymore unless
i'm not here in which case they're going
to reinstitute it worse
so the suburbs are not going to have
these projects forced
into them now who in the suburbs is not
going to vote for me
they're going to make the projects
bigger better they're putting corey
booker in charge i mean
one of the most liberal the most liberal
is kamala
but corey is right there and he's going
to be in charge of building projects in
the suburbs
you're going to destroy your suburbs
it's already happening because you see
what's going on you see what they've
done
they take over the zoning and they force
projects projects really
terrible cities are being destroyed and
the the combination of lawlessness and
the pandemic shut down new york city
and uh now the suburbs but you know well
the suburbs is going to be next look
yeah the suburbs are people these same
protesters but they're not protesters
they're anarchists
they're agitators and the rioters who
are they are they're people that in many
cases are paid
and then they're stupid kids uh were
they let's be the people that we're
looking at right now
we're looking at them right now can you
tell me no not yet but i'll
you'll be gonna be finding out pretty
soon look they're stupid people too
because they'll be overthrown as soon as
they get their wish
these people don't respect them they're
just using their money these are super
liberal people that have money
and they're helping these anarchists and
their agitators and their dangers
did you see what happened over the
weekend with the people walking up to a
restaurant and grabbing this
thing and biting the steak and then
dropping it down two
elderly people having dinner at a
restaurant and they walk in and they
take a steak and they take the potatoes
and that's exactly the problem
now you're waiting to be asked in
when does that when is that change when
do you cross the rubicon well in kenosha
they asked men
right and we did a job like nobody's
ever seen before
but if they don't ask you when they're
not allowed to do it
unless you do insurrection in which case
it's just not big enough for
insurrection
you won't do insurrection before you
don't need it you don't know not yet oh
i'd be willing to do it in a heartbeat
if you needed it but we don't need it
our national when do you need it our
national guard is so good
and so tough but they've been police
departments in places that we're talking
about seattle we were going into seattle
and they solved the problem the night
before we got there we were getting
ready to go they heard we were going in
do you hear ted wheeler's numbers
like 20 percent in portland ted wheeler
is a disaster he's a laughingstock
he went out to protest with the
so-called agitators
and they were going to destroy him they
were going to beat him up badly he
fortunately had security
but they were going to beat him up badly
the man is a disaster
if he would say come into portland
within a half an hour the whole thing
would be
he's not going to say that uh the
governor's gotten closer look what's
going on out there
the governor has gotten closer i spoke
to the governor two days ago
they're arresting a lot of people that
now we sent in the u.s marshals for the
killer the man that killed the young man
in the streets she shot him i mean it
was intelligent
cold-blooded killed him he didn't like
his hat or he didn't like something and
it wasn't a trump hat
right it was peaceful it was prayer it
was a lot it was a religious house right
and he shot him cold blood two and a
half days went by
and i put out when are you going to go
get him
and the u.s marshals went in to get him
and
in a short period of time they ended in
a gunfight this guy was a violent
criminal out of the mountain and the u.s
marshals killed him
and i will tell you something that's the
way it has to be
there has to be retribution when you
have crime like this
there can't be guys standing up that
want to fight
they want to fight you can't throw
bricks at people with shields
but the problem mr president you and i
both agree
the problem is there are now prosecutors
who are not prosecuting
the protesters this is like at a
grassroots level they're being funded by
socialists who are now electing people
like i used to
prosecute crime they're letting them go
so it's going to happen and this is a
shame
you're gonna have a backlash like you've
never seen if these people don't stop
because you have very smart very tough
people that aren't gonna take it anymore
and once they say we're not gonna take
it anymore it's gonna end in a very
vicious backlash
and that's a terrible thing how does it
end